alright guys quiet place everyone's
talking about it look I had a theory I
know I had an idea that you could do
multiple quiet places all over the world
cuz it happened all over the world did
you guys ever think about making a
Russian quiet place a French quiet place
and Irish quiet place to Australian
quiet place well the funny thing is you
mentioned that like the very first film
we thought in the back of our heads like
this hopefully we'll travel
internationally because there's no
dialogue to it but certainly the idea of
having different stories around the
world did cross our minds something that
we loved about the idea we hope
audiences really embraced us that this
could happen in anybody's backyard what
about you absolutely I mean I think it
would be very cool to see every single I
think it would be cool to have foreign
films like other filmmakers across the
world do their own version of the story
like how amazing that would that be as
long as you guys get a cut that's all
that matters that's the most important
thing um you guys have a film out now
haunt tell me about that yeah so hi we
were writing at the same time this quiet
place walk quiet place was what we would
consider the elevated version of horror
putting that in big quotes haunt was
very much a throwback to John Carpenter
and tobe Hooper so it's a slasher film
that takes place in a haunted house
attraction where they discover all the
horror that's happening there 100% reals
and it was so awesome because we got to
work with Eli Roth like he produced the
movie
Eli's the coolest he's one of the great
ambassadors for the horror genre and he
read the script fell in love with it he
always wanted to do a haunted house
movie and we got to partner with him on
it and it was honestly a dream come true
coolest guy ever all right you later off
to questions did he bring his bad from
inglorious basterds and - did he invite
you to the hotel did you guys get to go
to his hotel yeah and as far as the bath
there's actually no Majd inglourious
basterds one of the characters has a bat
and he knows how to use it just like
Donnie so what do you have going up next
after haunt so we have an adaptation of
Stephen King's the boogey man that we're
writing right now for Fox and Disney
rather so it's Disney's the boogeyman
now but it's very much a quiet place as
much as it is scary it's got a heart to
it it's about families and then we're
doing a top-secret project with Sam
Raimi right now we're going from here
and flying back to Vancouver and
shooting that and it's Sam is one of our
heroes and also happens to be the nicest
guy in the
business it's been so much fun that's
great you guys seem like nicest guys too
so thanks so much continued success to
both you